Let's have a quiz on this.
If all memcpys and kernel launch operations in the below code snippets
take exactly 1 second to complete,
what is the minimum time taken before the results are available on the host?
So here's the code snippets.
We'll start by declaring a couple of cudaStreams, s1 and s2,
and by using the cudaStreamCreate call to create streams with those stream objects.
And then there's are a bunch of code snippets,
and I want you to tell me how long each one is going to take, in seconds.
I've taken a couple of shortcuts here.
I haven't showed you d array, h array, d array 1, h array 1, 2.
I haven't showed you these things getting allocated.
You can assume that d_arr has been allocated with cudaMalloc
and it is a pointer to some device memory
and that h_arr has been allocated in pinned host memory using cudaHostMalloc.
And for a shorthand, I just abbreviated CUDA host to device as H2D
and CUDA device to host as D2H.
Notice that I'm launching a single block with a fairly small number of threads
in each of these thread launches.
So if all of these operations take 1 second,
what's the minimum time that each of them can take to complete?
What's the minimum time that it will be before the final results are ready for the host?